so the best way to experience the video
API is through a live demo and let's
start by taking this video of a
Superbowl commercial for Google home and
I'm gonna play the first few seconds we
can see that it starts with a mountain
landscape and we see a house a city
street then it goes to a dog and a
garage so lots of scene changes
happening in this video and if we were
to manually categorize what was
happening throughout it we need to watch
the entire thing and write down what was
happening in every scene
luckily the video API takes care of this
for us with just a single REST API
request so it tells us two things one at
a high level it tells us what is this
video about and then it also tells us at
a more granular level what labels it
finds in the video in each scene so if
we scroll down here we can see it
identifies a dog and it can tell us
exactly where in the video that dog
appears it also identifies at the end of
the video there's a birthday cake and if
we scroll down a bit more we can see
that not only does it know it's a dog it
knows what type of dog it is that it's a
Dashon and if we scroll down through the
rest of the labels we can see that it
also successfully identifies that
mountain past seen from the beginning so
this is what the API can do with one
video but you likely have more than one
video that you want to analyze so let's
take a look at how a company might use
the video intelligence API a media
publisher could have hundreds of
petabytes of video data sitting in
storage buckets and one common thing
they might want to do is create a
highlight reel focus on a specific type
of content or search their large library
for a specific entity so let's see how
we would use the video intelligence API
to search a large library of videos
given all this metadata that we get back
from it so we've got a lot of videos
here and let's say this media publisher
has hours of sports video but they only
want to find the content relevant to
baseball so let's go ahead and search
our library here for baseball videos and
we can see that not only does it show us
which videos have baseball it tells us
exactly when in those videos baseball
appears my favorite example is this one
we have this video which only has a tiny
bit about baseball but it's able to
identify that clip for us whereas if we
were to manually do this we'd have to
watch the whole video looking
for that specific scene so if we click
on this scene we can see that this is
from last year's year in search video
when the Cubs won the World Series so
let's do one more search I live on the
East Coast where it's pretty cold right
now I've heard there's been a ton of
rain in SF this past year I think we can
all agree it'd be pretty nice to be on a
beach right now
and while machine-learning can't take us
there it can do the next best thing
and find all the beach clips in our
video library for us so let's search for
our beach videos and then we can click
to all of our Beach clips in the videos
below so as you saw through this demo
the video intelligence API makes it easy
to quickly and easily understand a large
library of video content something that
was almost impossible just a few months
ago toss the tip that used to take hours
now take seconds with the video
intelligence API and I'm excited to make
it available to all of you today thank
you
[Applause]